رد روسيا اليوم هو أن هذه
الدبابات ستحترق مثل غيرها ما
هي رسالتك لروسيا اليوم لقد
أثبت الأوكرانيون مهارة كبيرة
وقدرة أه في تشغيل أه
المعدات الأسلحة التي قدمها حلفاء الناتو وشركاؤهم وهم على
يقين تام أنهم سيفعلون ذلك  قادرون
على القيام بذلك أيضًا باستخدام دبابات القتال الرئيسية
من الدول الحليفة لحلف شمال الأطلسي (الناتو) خاصةً
لأن
العديد منهم لديهم الكثير من الخبرة
بالفعل في الخطوط الأمامية أه
تشغيل المركبات المدرعة التي تعود إلى الحقبة السوفيتية
والدبابات القتالية ولكن بالطبع هذه
خلفية مفيدة عندما  ثم نبدأ
التدريب على الدبابات القتالية الحديثة ودبابات الناتو
علينا أن نتذكر ما هي هذه
الحرب أو العدوان. الرئيس بوتين
يغزو دولة مستقلة أخرى ذات سيادة
في أوروبا أوكرانيا أوكرانيا لديها
الحق في الدفاع عن النفس ولدينا
الحق في دعمها في التمسك بها.  أه
هذا صحيح
لأنه إذا فاز الرئيس بوتين فستكون
مأساة للأوكرانيين ولكن الأمر كله
خطير بالنسبة لنا لأن الرسالة هي
أنه عندما يستخدم القادة المستبدون
القوة العسكرية فإنهم يحصلون على ما يريدون
ومن ثم يصبح العالم أكثر
خطورة ونحن أكثر عرضة للخطر
وبالتالي  من مصلحتنا الأمنية
أن ندعم الأوكرانيين